I'm not gonna lie it's the most exciting
game for me personally on the stage all
day and today is two Witcher 3 and I'm
joined by Peter and John guys it's a
pleasure to have you here how you doing
wise right I was easy going so far for
you guys busy yeah I bet right your tan
buddy we got one of these dude oh yeah
oh yeah what's whatever how might eight
years later so I had it yesterday go
then it was like it seemed like it was a
great reception but tell me how you
thought it was yeah it's going really
great man people are coming out they're
really excited about because we're
showing the game behind you know behind
closed doors you know the secret part of
the game I closed doors people coming
out they're really excited about it and
they're getting a lot of applause man
they're really diggin it excellent well
we've actually got another kind of bit
of an exclusive right now some brand new
gameplay and you gameplay demo so we're
gonna go to that and I think a Peter
you're gonna talk us through right
exactly so em what here we go Oh menu
screen ah
that's key all right we're already there
so it's going to be a small snippet of
the demo we are presenting over at the
business booth we're in no-man's land
it's a huge region of our game and we're
right in the middle of the adventure we
got some information from a guy called
Dijkstra that Gareth is looking for a
certain person an ashen haired girl I
think it's pretty safe to talk about her
there's Siri and we're looking for a
small childlike creature in the swamps
so we are going to use our Witcher
senses to look for traces possible
traces of this small creature since
Geralt is a Witcher he has these
enhanced senses that enhance both
audible and visible clues so we can look
for all sorts of things leading to any
prey Geralt might have and here we are
so we have stumbled upon some smallish
footprints so we're going to follow them
should we're showing off our water
physics a lot near Oxford of water
partner item in a while yes and we're
going to showing off our combat a lot in
the sequence
Johnny
don't be afraid
you're a [ __ ]
godling not many of you left
I'm looking for a woman without hair
sooner
tell me everything from the start where
did you see her what was she doing it's
important to me
why not
lost your voice
can I help you somehow
can't understand you try to explain it
somehow
want me to follow you
no choice I guess
all right so Johnny apparently wants us
to help him regain his voice and since
its information we're looking for it
makes a lot of sense to follow him so
let's follow wherever he's taking us
through the swamps it's a really nice
place all sorts of points of interest
Dhalsim ocean we're on the main
storyline here that's exactly alright
we've seem to stumbled upon some
wildlife yep
we're gonna use some signs guys these
guys these are drown there yeah whenever
a nearby village or city guards want to
get rid of bodies they mostly dump them
in the swamps it's the easiest ways to
get rid of them and some of these bodies
come back as these vile creatures again
called drowners they pester travellers
and adventurers like us but we came
prepared as you saw all right
so let's follow Johnny a little bit
further we're gonna see some really
interesting things here I think you saw
some cutting limbs there so we implanted
a new sort of full dismemberment system
in the game it's not everything off
basically people seem to like that I
just do that when they leave that man in
- yes
on the ledge something that'll give me a
voice back
I guess I gotta make this climb
all right so I think we really don't
want to store the hotel spoil the whole
story for your audience because we still
have an entire game to spare for you so
it's like 50 our sort of main storyline
with the 50 our 100 our games so it's
like you really got to play it for a
long time to get into it but I think
this little snippet shows off some of
the story pulling storytelling features
in the game so what we just stand
watching that game running on there was
that a PC or is that ps4 what was that
build we just had a look at right here
it's playing on PC playing on PC right
okay so you mentioned the dismemberment
system that's killing you what else have
you added into combat
uh there's a we have refined combat a
lot it's very very tactical now while
being very casual of course this is a
very welcoming system just like the
story we would like to focus on
welcoming and inviting as many new
players as possible you don't have to
play any of the prequels to get engaged
in a story and the combat is likewise
very very approachable so it's you know
easy to learn hard to master there's a
lot of depth to adapt to it there's a
bunch of combat animation that makes it
makes it really really fluid it's really
enjoyable there's a lot to do here
so is it similar to the combat a
witchetty or he just wheats it slightly
or I mean is similar but it's been
refined a lot okay okay but it's just
all that emphasis on on countering and
dodging around because remember for me
that's certainly only the best way I
found a victory in many battles was to
make sure I can and make sure I jumped
out the way a lot this is still that
kind of you can't take many hits you
need to be careful about how you play
there's a bunch of that and of course
there's a lot of emphasis and sign usage
so it's a nice balanced pacing between
all the features we have in combat we
took it we took the backward roll out of
game though now so now it's just the
dodging system and there's a pretty
advanced parry system as well in the
game okay we also noticed in the M in
the demo yesterday that Daryl can now
jump finally you can jump so what made
you decide to give him a bit more
agility just is that just for connect
traversing read the water what one
really full immersion in the game so you
need to add the jump in so because you
can jump you have things obstacles you
can jump around so it's a pain to like
have to like run around a fence or
something like that so full immersion
requires like full capability of the
character you know speaking of that Phil
immersion let's really want to ask you
guys about the world of the waste your
three
described as an open-world so how open
is it I mean is it is it like Skyrim for
example where you can get wander
anywhere or is it in sections are all
connecting model sections very open very
open what you see is explorable really
if you see something you like you can
just go there and check it out there's
no digital limits this is why we
introduced jumping of course there we
really didn't want any digital
artificial barriers to gerelds
exploration so you can go basically
almost anywhere like it's like 35 times
bigger than the witcher 2 i think in
terms of size there are three big
regions in the game and everything is
contiguous we just measured some sizes
of the land recently and to gallop on
horseback full gallop from the north to
the south of no man's land and novigrad
it takes about I don't know 20 minutes
like full speed faster speed available
pretty huge me and is it to take great
take place across kind of quite
different environments because obviously
we we saw the kind of lush in a wooded
area there is it is it very other swampy
areas are there snowy areas evenly three
main regions to game we've got Zachary
called Skellig ah and it's kind of based
on skin and avian ethology in Nordic
mythology okay
but it's fjords and Iowans and stuff
that's where you use the boat a lot I've
got no-man's land which kind of a
desolate space more business or drive
brothers by Warren family as we told
it's really downtrodden the interesting
and mysterious and dark and we have
novigrad of course the city that you
might have seen it's really huge and
it's inspired by medieval ends for
Amsterdam so it's a city and all the
surrounding here is the city but it's a
massive like 8 by 8 kilometer area at
this how about the M how about the story
and the interplay of choosing your
quests cuz I was one of that to the wait
you know in the wait should see it was
you were always on your single-player
narrative but then along the way you
could kind of think and choose which
additional things you did is it the same
in the wait for three or is it more is
it more open can you kind of just do
anything at any time
how's that work yeah I mean there's
there's a really important main
storyline but you can approach it in a
lot of different ways so it's builds
very nonlinear and it's very lateral so
you could you might have different plot
paths going along the game that you can
move across and laterally in a way this
is what we introduced the open world
basically we like to say we want to give
room to explore the story and it
required a massive open world so the
solutions are not only dialog choices
like I want to help you I'm not going to
help you I'm going to enter the city
from this direction and then alters and
modifies and affects a lot of things and
so on and you can always jump off a
quest and go do some open-world stuff
that's fantastic
so you mentioned there's dimension this
boats I mean how does I work in with
your way you traverse the world I mean
they'd be able to use boats how does
that kind of work in with how you
expense you around well you know in the
world yeah we have fast travel system so
you can actually fast travel around but
you need to explore the areas and unlock
these sort of fast travel points so
let's Galaga this is lots of islands and
offshore things you got to take the boat
out there to actually find out where to
go and you know in quest out there or
monster hunt out there
then you unlock it and you can fast
travel back for fast travel there so
photos two means of navigation and means
it means to travel first and foremost
there's also horse and you can scale
cliffs so basically what we're saying is
everything you can see in the game you
can actually go to so you need a way to
get there
there's also underwater and they have
tons of ways though he's in waste get
around that um one of the one of my
favorite things about the waster - was
that it it was it was challenging and it
didn't feel like even though you're the
production values were incredibly high
it was very slick it didn't feel like uh
like most other games the way I thought
about it was like you know you go see a
really great like say Swedish cinema
film it's equally as high production
value as Hollywood but it just feels
different
g-guys are you aware of that kind of it
doesn't feel like a West you know like
an American game or a British game or
whatever ie are you aware of trying to
keep that I maintain that yeah course
this is a lucky thing that we are
situated in Poland because we were
inspired by Slavic mythology a lot and
it's kind of related to a European
mainstream of course but it has a lot of
unique approaches so that affects story
that affects sounds the music we are
using all the characters the monsters
and beasts Geralt reactions dialogue and
everything so you're really
a one-of-a-kind experience in the game
yeah I think Slavic myth is kind of
alien to us Americans you know so it
does feel different when you play it
because you've heard fairy tales told
from different perspective and then this
is completely something we never
actually experienced we were going up so
it's it's a completely new feeling for
players I think which is cool one of its
I really again I judge wish or tune that
facets of Daryl being a witch sure is
the the idea of monster hunting is that
it seems like we the trailer you showed
up yesterday Geralt that wasn't part of
the story he was just hunting a Griffin
in like a random encounter is what it
seemed like is there going to be a lot
of hunting choices just like as you
adventure through the world that's how
it works basically what we like to say
is these creatures however large
dangerous and hard to defeat are not
bosses at the end of dungeons they roam
the wilderness they're part of the fauna
so you can stumble upon them when you're
exploring or you can stumble upon their
tracks and marks that you can discover
using The Witcher senses that we just
introduced minutes earlier you can hear
local gossip and villages that a large
creature is taking livestock and all
sorts of things so there are many many
ways to pick these up it's not it
doesn't feel artificial at all I like it
depends on where you are what you're
doing
the discovery can be tied to main quests
or sudden occurrences coincidences it
feels real I'm also thinking about
monsters and my enemies in general and
so are they going to be exhale you start
off so you start off the game pretty
early on and you come across a trail for
something really nasty so when really
dangerous is that thing gonna kill you I
mean do do basically why I'm asking is
do enemy this enemy difficulty not ready
to scale though your ability or is it
just there as hard as they are and you
better be ready for a fight
or you're gonna die yeah we don't talk
about a player there are a lot of
healthy challenges that you will need to
prepare basically it's part of being a
Witcher part of the previous games and
we like to maintain the heritage that
there's a lot of preparation and
planning ahead there's a lot of features
supporting that kind of an approach to
the to plan the things to prepare with
calm Kaneko concoctions all sorts of
potions scouting around discovery and so
on so we still have that
lassic are you guys gonna because I want
liked as well is am when you did the
kind of the newer versa the way too soon
you you included that kind of training
combat training arena system is that
gonna be something you bring back maybe
or is that really your in and don't you
know that's a good we cooperated to it
already perhaps yeah what's uh know it's
read it was cool but we're just not
playing it do it and then what you to
it's something we added afterwards as
well you know so maybe we'll find reason
to add an arena but people asked for it
and love it maybe then we'll do it yeah
yeah so when can we expect to a wake me
expect to get our hands on the way to
three I mean it's I think I've got it
then its 24th of February 2015 alright
yeah so it's it is next year's no 2050
game since I all the ones I'm really
excited about at e3 so far made like
2015 it's gonna be a good year in a good
year I'm just gonna be on what platforms
again are we gonna be able to play the
wishes through here so what platforms
are we gonna be able to play witcher 3
all major platforms PC ps4 Xbox one go
well guys thank you so much for coming
on stage after showing us one gameplay
for talking away the way to three it's
been a pleasure source been a bit lies
over here our other stage is too noisy
Danish he'll be quiet before very life
thanks very much man thanks we're gonna
throw over now and to I think a show
floor so let's go find out what's been
going on right on the show floor 83